Kanye West said in an interview that the
only slavery in America four hundred
years on is mental imprisonment
voluntary mental imprisonment at which
point a bunch of ignorant people proved
his point on Twitter and elsewhere Kanye
is entirely correct we will explain who
knew that in an age of sexless Boy
Scouts senseless Democrats and
Californians banning Christian books a
frequently incoherent rap artist named
Kanye Omari West would be the voice of
one crying out in the wilderness who
knew then on this day in history the
demise of James Edgar Comey I'm cyber
website i mean j edgar hoover ends five
decades of anti-constitutional overreach
at the FBI I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
I should clarify by the way because
sexless Boy Scouts is it is a general
and confusing term I I too was a sexless
Boy Scout but I'm talking about sexless
meaning having neither a gender or no
specific gender not not the way in which
I was a sexless Boy Scout sad also are
we ever gonna do a show again that isn't
just about Kanye West it's like this is
gonna be the new show Kanye is the new
co f fa cai fa i don't know we have a
lot to talk about today and i it's on
the the thing that Kanye said has caused
universal condemnation everyone is is
screaming and wailing and gnashing their
teeth what he said is completely right
we'll get to that in a second before we
get to that we have to talk about toys
we have to talk about toys so we get to
talk about this story this story is so
cool man I it makes me upset that I am
an adult many things make me upset that
I'm an adult like accountability and
having to pay bills and taxes and all
that but this more than any of them
little bits little bits is the coolest
toy ever that's it it's the coolest toy
ever if you have a kid or a niece or
whatever even if you're thirty get it
it's the coolest toy ever a little bit's
is an award-winning platform of easy to
use electronic building blocks for
creating inventions large and small you
know we all had those building blocks
when we were kids and various versions
of them this is just the insanely way
cooler version of all of that you can
get the complete droid kit that's what
they sent to me
when you when we on-boarded them this
thing I was walking through the office
because I thought oh that's good I'll
send it to my nephew I'll send it to my
you know my nephew will really like this
hordes of 30 year old daily wire
employees are trying to take my toy from
me they're trying to take a toy from my
little nephew it's really really cool
he loves it he was so excited when I
called and told him I was sending this
to him yeah you can work it on a mobile
device so there are six bits twenty
droid parts three sticker sheets there's
a free app you can go to drive mode
force mode self navigation all these
authentic sounds from the Star Wars
movies 22 missions in the app
customizable droids you can give them
personality and kids learn to code so
you can code while you're doing it it
requires a smart device
very cool to control from your app that
is why my nephew loves little bits and
loves this droid kid get yours right now
get $10 off a droid inventor kit
go get it seriously you always need a
gift for some kid for Christmas or
whatever this is the one get it now and
you'll save 10 bucks
little bits comm slash anoles KO wles
get the toy Association's 2018 12 the
year for your kids and inspire in
vention little bits comm / knowles KO
wles for $10 off a droid inventor kit
it's really really cool you know what
else is really cool
kanye west keeps saying true things he
keeps saying this guy I'm not a huge
Kanye West fan now I am but I've never
it's not like I listen to Kanye West all
the time I think he has a couple songs
that are pretty good I think he was
hugely important for hip-hop I think he
made hip hop much much better because he
actually does have a brilliant musical
ear a great year for how music should go
even if I don't like his own music and
even if he's great for hip hop even if
he's the best thing that ever happened
to hip hop which he probably is I don't
like hip hop
nevertheless I really like what he's
saying he just came out and he said
before we even get to the slavery that
that's the most controversial quote he's
been saying these great things over the
last few days he's been talking about
Candace Owens I actually tweeted out
someone said you shouldn't like Candace
Owens she's only repeating Thomas soul
quotes the wonderful great economist
Thomas soul and I said well even if
that's all Candace is doing and I don't
agree with that but even if that's all
she's doing Kanye West isn't gonna tweet
Thomas soul quotes and that tweet did
not age well maybe it's like two days
later Kanye West actually tweeted quotes
from the famed 80 something-year-old
economist unbelievable political thinker
Thomas soul so this is all great the new
one he sent out is Kanye said that
Barack Obama is like opioids for black
people
Oh bomb ax is opioids for black people
and this is a brilliant analogy he said
it Bhama made us feel good but it didn't
fix any of the underlying problems
basically it didn't actually fix the
symptoms it made us feel really good but
it didn't do anything a perfect analogy
it's very timely because with
the opioid crisis is happening its
headline granite grabbing because it's
so sensational and it's correct and the
reasoning here is excellent all of the
problems that Barack Obama could have
filled there were racial problems he
could have healed the racial divide in
America once and for all he chose not to
do that he chose to stoke the flames of
racial divide and to say that kids who
had been beating up a Hispanic
neighborhood watch people were like his
children they looked like his children
they didn't look what it didn't look
like Barack Obama the premise of that is
that all black people look alike all
black people don't look alike they're
individuals he Kanye West I'm beginning
to think this guy is smarter than people
give him credit for I'm not saying he's
a great genius I'll get to that at the
end I'm not saying he's playing for DHS
or something but he clearly has an eye
and an ear for something that is
stronger than people give him credit for
he also tweeted at another analogy he
said when the media masses and scholars
talk about what started today here's a
title the overground hell Road and
people are using this to say well he
doesn't the Kanye West doesn't know what
he's talking about he's saying these
kind of incomprehensible things and he
does this he does say strange things and
just like any artist he says strange
things but especially Kanye West except
it's a great analogy the overground hell
road first of all what is he saying
started today is he talking about the
where we are in America is he talking
about all of the attacks that he's
getting is he what is he talking about
and you have the Underground Railroad
that's what he's alluding to Harriet
Tubman's Underground Railroad the the
system of getting slaves out of slavery
and up to the free North but this is
over ground what is the overground hill
road I think it's really important
because it plays on a line the road to
hell is paved with good intentions there
are all of these good intentions that
you hear especially from the left they
say oh you know we want to give black
people this this extra bit of money or
this extra advantage in hiring or this
extra advantage in admissions or this
welfare program or this government
program or this subsidy or this or this
or this and that safety net becomes
a spiderweb and it keeps people
entangled in the road to hell is paved
with good intentions but it's a road to
hell anyway and it's it's over ground
it's out in the open it's government
policy it's in the mainstream media and
what Kanye West is saying that the
thread that has gone through all of his
tweets and all of his interviews is I
want to be free I just want to be free I
want to have free thought I want to have
free speech this and all of these people
John Legend was texting him and saying
think of your fans think of your legacy
don't say this don't think this and he
said look John I love you I appreciate
what you're trying to do but you're
bringing up my fans and my legacy to
shut me up and to say that I can't think
this or I can't say this and I'm not
going to do it because I want to be free
that's a beautiful sentiment that is a
beautiful sentiment and the analogy to
the Underground Railroad is apt and the
pitfalls of good intentions the
allusions to hell and the sort of
hellish civic culture that we have now
that is apt those are excellent
analogies so he he goes on to talk about
slavery here well let's just play the
clip you can hear Kanye say himself you
hear about slavery for 400 years for 400
years that's not like a choice like you
was there for 400 years and it's all
y'all this is the big one this is the
one people are saying how dare you can't
everyone is saying this conservatives
are saying this left lefties are saying
this this was the top trend on Twitter
because the headline was Kanye West says
that slavery was a choice except he
didn't say that
Kanye West just saying that black slaves
in America chose to be slaves and they
chose to put themselves in bondage and
come over on the Middle Passage and end
up in the Americas except he didn't said
it and Kanye went except he didn't say
that I don't know do I need to pull a
gunk out of people's ears that when
Kanye West said that this was the
reaction from just about everybody on
Twitter and in reality
that's I think that's a livestream
because it's still happening really how
could you
by the way Kanye West clarified what he
said Kanye West said verbatim when you
hear about slavery for 400 years for 400
years that sounds like a choice like you
were there for 400 years and it's all of
you all like we're mentally in prison
slavery goes to direct to the idea of
blacks so prison mental prison is
something that unites us as one race
blacks and whites being one race were
the human race beautiful absolutely
correct absolutely spot-on will I am who
I guess is some entertainer or something
that I know nothing about he said he was
deeply hurt he was so offended he was so
deeply hurt alleged comedian ty Barnett
another person I've never heard of said
Kanye West needs to shut the F up I he
was more colorful language he literally
said you have to shut up that's that's
by the way how you know that Kanye is in
the right is that everyone's telling him
to shut up everybody's telling him to
shut up that's how you know he's in the
right because when you're in the right
you don't need to shut other people up
you can let them make a fool for
themselves you say you know when when
you're in the right and someone else is
saying crazy things and is in the wrong
the best strategy you have the best
tactic at your disposal is to just let
them keep talking right but if you're in
the wrong or if you're trying to push a
wrong agenda or an oppressive agenda or
you have your own nefarious plots and
someone is speaking the truth what you
have to do is tell them to shut up
you've got to keep them quiet I will
explain why historically and
mathematically kanye west is obviously
correct how everyone with even a passing
knowledge of history or math knows that
Kanye West is 100% correct about slavery
before we get to that kind of talk to
you about sheets let's talk about some
sheets the these guys you've heard me
talk about Bolin branch before Bolin
branch sheets this was such an elevation
in my life because as you know I try to
sleep at least 18 or 19 hours a day you
know I come in here basically a
Britt a little Co FFA for a while and
then I go back and I go to sleep but I
would always buy these really not nice
sheets just whatever the cheapest thing
was I didn't realize sheets could be so
nice as Boland branch getting a great
night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
to get a new expensive mattress you
don't need to take sleeping pills just
change your sheets seriously I had no
idea what a difference really nice
sheets can make now when you look I'm
you know I'm getting married soon you
look on the wedding registries really
nice sheets can cost up to $1,000 more
than $1,000 and I listen Ben doesn't pay
me anything and he certainly doesn't pay
me enough to buy really nice sheets so
Boland branch with what you do is you
can buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices you
can get luxury sheets that should be
over a thousand dollars in the store
Boland branch will only cost you a
couple hundred bucks I am telling you
treat yourself even if you don't spend
19 hours a day as sleeping like I do you
you still should treat yourself this is
you're gonna feel like a king and you
can do it for just a couple hundred
bucks everyone who tries bond branch
will love us them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company everybody's talking about Boland
branch three u.s. presidents sleep on
Boland branch sheets three us Brett
they're probably a lot of jokes that one
could make about that but I'm going to
avoid that and I just point out three
u.s. presidents the highest office in
the entire world they choose these
sheets shipping is free and you can try
them for 30 nights so I know a lot of
you were lying and gutter as most of the
time and what you can do you just try it
for 30 nights no shipping and you at
least get a good night's sleep for a
month that sounds pretty good if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund I really don't think that you'll
want to send them back there's no risk
there is absolutely no reason not to
give them a try this is one of those
things you say oh I don't need that I
don't need to worry about my sheets do
it man I'm telling you you will not
regret it you will thank me for saving
you a lot of time and giving you good
sleep for a long time
to get started right now my listeners
get $50 off your first set of sheets at
Boland branch com promo code Michael mi
CH AE L go to Boland branch comm today
for $50 off your first set of sheets Bo
LL and branch comm promo code Michael mi
CH AE L they are really really good back
how absolutely accurate kanye west's
here he said again I'd like to get this
quote right when you hear about slavery
for 400 years for 400 years that sounds
like a choice like slavery goes to
direct like you were there for 400 years
and it's all of you all like we're
mentally in prison for hundred years he
said that's the number for hundred years
so when did slavery when did African
slavery get introduced to the Americas
the Dutch introduced African slavery to
the Americas in 1619 that was the first
time now slavery had existed in the
Americas long before that since the dawn
of time a lot of so-called indigenous
peoples or Native Americans or whatever
the euphemism du jour is the people who
were here before the Europeans they all
enslaved one another there was rampant
slavery as there was throughout the
entire world especially outside of the
West but even at various times in the
West in antiquity now this was 1619 when
the Dutch introduced African slavery to
the Americas one of the first legally
recognized slave owners in America came
just a few decades later in 1655
ironically it was a black man a black
man named Anthony Johnson he was a black
Angolan and though in the case or suit
the Virginia recognized his right to own
a slave now 1619 was when the Dutch
brought African slaves to America
slavery was abolished in 1865 246 years
later so that was the Thirteenth
Amendment the end of the Civil War 246
years later slavery was abolished now
that that is the largest count if you
include go all the way back to the Dutch
not the English not the American
Founding in the late 18th century just
the very first time by the largest count
black people were in some black people
were enslaved in America for 246 years
we know that slavery existed everywhere
threat history and we know that only in
the West was slavery abolished and it
was abolished pretty quickly because of
Christianity 246 years the entire
history of the world thousands and
thousands of years it existed in the
modern West for 246 years and we
abolished it now for 400 years of
slavery to be true
as all these myung mooing crewing people
who were apparently lightly educated on
Twitter and elsewhere and in the media
are saying for 400 years of slavery to
be true slavery would have had to
continue 153 years after it did after
1865 which would take us to 2019 which
is one year in the future so not only
would slavery have to have persisted in
the United States as a matter of law
from 1865 to the present that not only
would there have to be rampant legal
slavery in America today it would have
to continue until next year and we would
count that we would have to be living in
the future for that to be true so if you
think that you have been enslaved for
400 years in America that is a choice
that's an absurdity that's not true it
is a mental prison that's a mental
prison that you live in
Kanye explained all of this he said
quote the reason why I brought up the
400 years point is because we can't be
mentally imprisoned for another 400
years we need free thought now even the
statement was an example of free thought
it was just an idea and what did she get
for that free thought Kanye you got
piled on by a bunch of people who can't
even do basic math they can't even do
basic math that if black people were
enslaved legally in America for 400
years we would be living in the future
and the Civil War would never have
happened
150 years ago the this he makes this
great point said the reason I brought
this up one is to exercise my free
thought and to show you all what happens
when you dare to exercise free thought
to quote Clarence Thomas when someone
Dane's to think for himself and not
kowtow to an older racist order he said
that in his famous high-tech lynching
defense Oh but also we can't be enslaved
for another 400 years what he's saying
is this is a mental prison this is a
choice and it will persist if you don't
think for yourself if you don't have
your mind this will go on forever there
will be no end to that slavery only you
can undo that slavery there's a really
good slave narrative Kanye West got me
thinking about slave narratives and
there's a really wonderful one
old incidents in the life of a slave
girl written by herself by Harriet
Jacobs it's it's the best slave
narrative I've ever read and it's really
eloquently written the sheer I it's
Harriet Jacob writes quote I would ten
thousand times rather that my children
should be the half-starved paupers of
Ireland then to be the most pampered
among the slaves of America the felons
home in a penitentiary is preferable he
may repent and turn away from the error
of his ways and so find peace but it is
not so with a favorite slave she is not
allowed to have any pride of character
it is deemed a crime in her to wish to
be virtuous this explains how insidious
slavery is this explains why the West
got rid of it why the West's Christian
culture and the culture that came from
Christianity forced it very quickly
almost immediately to do away with
slavery threat its territories because
slavery isn't about material things or
luxury or money a lot of people today
who are race hustlers want to say the
effects of slavery the the heritage of
slavery is poverty or not nice living
conditions or whatever very few people
are poor for a long time in America it's
almost impossible to be poor for a long
time in America if you're poor in
America you still have television and
microwaves and it's pretty nice unless
you have a drug habit or a mental
illness or something like that and can't
can't exercise liberty mmm it's a pretty
luxurious life we live in a materially
wealthy culture that isn't the problem
it is true a lot of times you'll hear
people say slaves in certain parts of
the South in America had it better than
poor people in Europe and that's both
true and false
it is it is materially true if you think
of slavery just in material terms that
is true they and you hear people write
about this in slave narratives that
actually slaves had better material
conditions than poor people in Europe
but it isn't true they didn't have it
better because they were deprived of
something essential much more important
than luxury which is liberty they were
deprived of liberty and I'd rather be a
poor guy with nothing and free then a
very wealthy sleigh
if we all would do that Jacobs is
alluding to have slavery harms even the
slave owners by depriving even the slave
owners of virtue she she understands
something that so many geniuses in the
West don't understand today it's a point
that Andrew Clavin talks about a lot
which is that our primary motivations
are not money our primary motivations
aren't sex like all of them all of the
New Atheists tell you all of the guru
types they say all we were really driven
by sex we're really driven by money
we're really driven by blablablablabla
no what we're driven by isn't is a need
for virtue a need to be virtuous and to
use our Liberty to shape ourselves to do
the good and in this slave narrative she
identifies it perfectly the slave can't
be virtuous it's a crime for the slave
to be virtuous because there's no
freedom and slavery is so insidious
because it deprives the slave master of
virtue because he is partaking of this
horrible ripping away of Liberty because
he is denying Liberty he himself cannot
be virtuous he cannot pursue the virtue
he's stuck in this awful peculiar
institution which she quotes in this
slave narrative she quotes Byron the
poet Lord Byron says each is tortured in
his separate hell these are separate
hell's but they're equally torturous
that is what Kanye is identifying he's
identifying this central problem
ironically better than virtually anybody
else the central problem of Liberty the
Liberty here to pursue virtue this isn't
about money this isn't about keeping
yourself in the past this isn't about
even historical ignorance it's about
liberty and virtue and listen I don't
want to be accused of painting too rosy
a picture of Kanye here he's making
excellent points and he's making very
important points but I don't think he's
playing for DHS this is what they're
gonna say for DHS was invented by
critics of Donald Trump especially on
the right who said that his supporters
were thought he was the greatest genius
in the world that isn't true we don't
think he's like the greatest strategic
genius ever in the whole world we think
he's good at the media and he's and he's
a pretty smart fella who's succeeded in
some of the most competitive industries
in the entire world and managed to get
himself elected president the first time
he tried we think he's a pretty smart
fella that's what I think about
Kanye West but I don't think he's some
great genius here's actually how I know
because he tweeted out he said if this
was 148 years ago I would have been more
like Harriet or NAT would have been like
Harriet Tubman or Nat Turner now I
wonder why did he say a hundred forty
eight years ago hundred forty eight
years ago was 1870 but that was after
slavery ended so what does it mean to be
Harriet Tubman after slavery is
abolished what does it mean to be
natural or after slavery is abolished
five years after the end of the Civil
War and I just googled I had a hunch so
I googled how long ago to this slavery
end in America and the first result says
148 years ago but it's an article from
2013 so I think that's it right I think
that's probably explains it it's off the
top of his head kind you said how long
ago did slavery and okay I'll use that
number and so I'm not saying he's a
Rhodes Scholar I'm not saying he's this
great political philosopher but he's
making extraordinarily important points
and he has a virtue the courage to
withstand the leftist onslaught that he
is currently getting from everybody and
it's not just on Twitter and it's not
just on TMZ or whatever stupid
television shows he's going on he's
getting it in text messages from friends
of his and family and people who are
saying you're mentally ill you're a
traitor you're this you're that and he's
and he's got this manliness a harvey
mansfield writes about it that even a a
manly virtue is to be confident and to
pursue the right as you see the right
even when you lack perfect knowledge
even when you lack technical knowledge
even when you lack total detailed
knowledge it's why kanye west is similar
to donald trump it's why they share
dragon energy because when Donald Trump
entered the race he certainly didn't
possess a perfect knowledge of public
policy or foreign policy but he he just
knew what he thought he knew his vision
for the country
he knew the motivating principles the
premises and he followed them and he
wouldn't allow himself to be intimidated
by all these little technical soy boys
who say man well you didn't read this
book when we went know that he speak
confidently and they're right even if
Kanye West is off by a few years on the
tweet the point he's making is right
and speaking of manliness we got to burn
through this we got
more stories we got to talk about
speaking of Manliness the Boy Scouts are
now the Girl Scouts which has come as a
surprise to the Girl Scouts who are
about to disappear is that confusing
this we'd like to cut really quickly to
Steven Tyler for comment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that sums it up yeah that that is what
you know this is the evidence of that
manliness because a Steven Tyler I don't
know if he knows everything about this
issue at the Boy Scouts but he can
really cut to the core of what it is
I think Boy Scouts are no longer at the
Boy Scouts they're now called the scouts
BSA this I just bring this topic up to
show that leftist ideologies are
essentially about destruction they're
not about creating new things they're
about destroying traditions they're not
about creating the Girl Scouts the Girl
Scouts already existed actually what
they're doing now is this pernicious
ideology of saying that men and women
are exactly the same that destroys the
Girl Scouts right by it doesn't create
the new Scouts it just destroys them and
makes it all this bland gray thing and
frankly I'm surprised it took this long
because we live in a gender neutral
society we've lived in the gender
neutral society increasingly for a long
time now I'm surprised the Boy Scouts
even managed to continue to exist and
this gets to the point even
conservatives will say oh who cares
about the bathrooms
who cares about if men can use the
women's room or if there's a law that
says men have to be able to use the
women's room who cares about redefining
marriage who cares about it well we all
have gay friends we want them to be
happy who cares about redefining that
the central relationship in a human
nature
who cares about what's so marriage for
all of history meant the union of
husbands and wives and now it means you
know it includes monogamous people of
the same sex but only two of them for
some reason not three and then who cares
it's what's the deal it's look this is
not a debate about rights this is about
the abuse of language I just did a
Praeger video on this and the Boy Scouts
proved me right you can trace the demise
of the voice gets to the success of the
gender-neutral society the words contain
whole premises and when you control the
language you control the culture the
founding mission of the Boy Scouts in
1910 was to teach boys patriotism
courage self-reliance and kindred values
courage self-reliance but the
gender-neutral Society says that virtues
manifest in exactly the same way
they do for men as they do for women so
in the old days in the old days before
like five minutes ago
we used to say well courage for men and
courage for women can look quite
different so to have an unwanted
pregnancy or a pregnancy that you didn't
expect and then to carry that child to
term and then to raise that child
sometimes on your own
that's unfathomable courage that is
profound courage
that's a courage that only women have
access to men can't do that men can't do
that courage now slaying entire armies
of Philistines with the jawbone of an
axe that's a more manly courage so you
don't expect women to do that because
they're not as physically strong so acts
of physical courage or 10 tend to be
reserved for men women just can't do
that if they compete with men in acts of
physical courage they're gonna lose
but the gender-neutral Society says no
it has to be the same it has to be the
same so the the Boy Scouts of America
the current participation rate is 2.3
million that's down from 2.6 million in
2013 which is down from 4 million in the
peak years of the past but I'm surprised
it took this long the Boy Scouts of
America doesn't make any sense in the
gender-neutral Society why would you
have Boy Scouts if there's no difference
between boys and girls that's what we're
taught that's what I was taught in in
public school I was taught there's no
difference but never hit a girl but
there's no difference between boys and
girls all the differences are
superficial and meaningless but you
should hold the door and pay the check I
don't understand how do those things how
can that possibly be true the genders
the biological sexes are entirely
identical they're interchangeable
they're indiscernible but also there are
these different rules that you have to
follow you say well maybe the sexes are
complementary we know with with the
language here the language changes the
culture we started using gender-neutral
language we started abusing language
that changes the culture and the culture
changes the institutions and this might
take years to happen might take decades
to happen as it has in this case but
ultimately the institution of the Boy
Scouts will be changed as well and this
even changes political institutions and
government institutions you see this
David French wrote a wonderful article
at National Review about how California
knew long
fornia would ban certain Christian books
there's a new California law a B 2943
which would ban certain Christian books
the bill declares quote sexual
orientation change efforts or to be
quote an unlawful business practice
sexual orientation change efforts now
that's like you know if a if sweet
little ELISA wants to change my sexual
behavior and say Michael stop it
don't stop it don't go you know good
then that I guess that would be a change
effort wouldn't I don't know what is a
sexual orientation change effort that is
such a broad phrase and as is business
practice it's so broad that it could ban
books the bill applies to services and
goods
it bans quote the sale or release of
goods or services that would attempt to
change sexual orientation it also bans
advertising offering to engage in or
engaging in sexual orientation change
efforts with an individual so if you
tell someone that their sexual behavior
maybe should change if you even just
suggest that to a person if you
advertise that that would be against the
law the left wants to pretend that we're
talking about electro electrocution
therapy or something here like there's
an wide epidemic of electrocuting gays
in America which I don't have any of you
ever seen that have you ever heard of
that or known someone that that's
happened to because I haven't I know a
lot of gay people you know I'm from New
York and I live in LA and I went to Yale
where it's one in four maybe more in
these days it's one in three maybe me
who knows I haven't you don't know
everything about me
but on but the but now we're talking
about something that could include books
we're talking about something that even
could include books this is a huge
overreach you'll probably have to
rewrite the law now because everyone's
denying that that's the case but this is
what happens you control the language
and you have these mental prisons it's
exactly as Kanye West is alluding to
there is a hopeful note I'll leave you
on before I say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube
you can't stump Trump you can't stump
Trump now we have leak to interview
questions apparently from the Muller
investigation into Trump they're leaking
all of this Muller wants to subpoena
Trump apparently a Democrats who are
running on the nothing burger Russia
narrative in the words of Van Jones have
bankrupted
Michael Caputo a trump campaign aide
they bankrupted him computo has had to
sell his house jeopardize his kids
education because he's had $125,000 in
legal fees all because as he points out
Democrats lost an election so they
decided to bankrupt this guy CNN has had
stormy Daniels as a lawyer on 59 times
in two months CNN a CNN is absurd it has
really I see it sometimes at the airport
now and it's become insane the CNN
headline today that went to all the
iPhones you would see it in Apple news
was Mike Pence did a dumb thing in
Arizona yesterday that was the headline
that's CNN facts first
CNN facts there's a facts but I'm a
banana I don't forget what their
advertisers was that's it Mike Pence did
a dumb thing and the dumb thing was that
they compliment he complimented a
politician CNN doesn't like as the
that's breaking news Facebook is
admitting to censoring conservatives
Mark Zuckerberg admitted to a new system
on Tuesday it will rank a new sites by
trust which explains why all the right
leaning pages have seen all of their
engagement drop to nothing and yet
despite all of that Donald Trump's daily
approval rating is 49 percent all of
that they are doing everything they can
to destroy this guy and yet half the
country exactly half the country
approves of him it's perfectly divided
forty-nine percent approved forty-nine
percent disapprove voter confidence in
the u.s. winning war on terror is the
highest it's been since we killed Osama
bin Laden voters still support president
Trump's temporary ban on immigrants from
dangerous countries despite the constant
negative press coffe FA abounds this is
a really wonderful thing I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
we've got a great this day in history
where I talk about James Edgar Comey and
the politicization of the FBI so you're
gonna want to stick around for that but
if you're on Facebook and YouTube I'm
sorry folks you've got to go over to
daily wire.com we've got really exciting
news this Sunday we're going to have the
Ben Shapiro show Sunday special debut
this is gonna be a new long-form
interview show with Ben he's going to
have the best and brightest political
and thought leading voices in America
come on the show the first guest is
Jordan B Peterson it's gonna be really
good do not miss it and if you're a
bench of Shapiro subscribe or blah blah
blah if you're a Ben should be
Oh show subscriber already it will just
pop up in your feed so you'll get to see
that right there it's gonna be really
cool so check it out this Sunday also
daily wire is on Apple news now so if
you don't want to just read mike pence
does a dumb thing now you can you can
also get the daily wire to
counterbalance all the fake news from
CNN plus sign up folks because what do
you get you get me they enter claim and
show the ben shapiro show you get all of
those extra perks and you get to ask
questions in the conversation the next
one stars little old me so make sure you
sign up before then you can have your
questions answered in the order that
they come in it's going to be a lot of
fun none of that matters mmm oh it's
still warm because you can surf the the
leftist here's hot or cold in this
tumbler oh the kanye vintage is just
it's just magnificent it the the aroma
when it first the first notes are
flavors of angry hip-hop stars and CNN
commentators and everybody else on
twitter but then when you when you get
it on the palate you get how horrified
the leftists are at truth so you get
everything all make sure you get this is
the only fda-approved vessel to drink
the salty and delicious leftist ears hot
or cold I'm having mine hot right now
cuz I'm feeling a little saucy today go
to daily wire.com we'll be right back to
talk about James Edgar coming up Hoover
zooms at J groove
that's a Freudian slip the the Hoover in
the coma me that a Freudian slip is
where you say one thing but mean your
mother I keep doing I don't know why I
keep doing it with Hoover and Comey on
this day in history in 1972 J Edgar
Hoover died after five decades running
the FBI now we talked today we talk
about the FBI is this the Central
American institution if you criticize
the FBI oh what are you you're attacking
America
the FBI was created in 1908 whoever took
over sixteen years later he ran the
thing for five decades this ties in with
today's theme by the way the firt when
the FBI was first founded the first task
of the FBI in those days was to
investigate and shut down whorehouses in
the enforcement of the white slave
Traffic Act basically there was what we
would call sex trafficking today and it
was one of its first assignments was to
shut that down whoever took over in 1924
and he turned this pretty inefficient
agency into an extremely powerful
crime-fighting organization so Hoover
gets a lot of flack I will defend J
Edgar Hoover at the beginning and then
I'll attack him at the end there was
great stuff in the early years of Hoover
do not believe the fake news he
curtailed the massive influence of the
FBI or of the FBI of the KKK but another
fourteen slip of the KKK that was
growing in the 1920s he shut that down
he investigated grizzly Indian murders
he apprehended or killed very notorious
criminals who had been on the run John
Dillinger babyface Nelson Bob Barker
Machine Gun Kelly all those names that
you think of as cartoon characters
basically he caught him as early as the
1920s the FBI started wiretapping people
to enforce prohibition this is when
things started to get a little dicey but
it was hugely effective they were they
were able to do a lot against organized
crime now the FBI also because they had
all this information on people they
started compiling lists of Japanese
German and Italian Americans in the
run-up to World War two they said if we
went to war with the axis we might have
to put these people in detention camps
let's just get their names here just in
case that's just in case ok that's fine
and we know that that happened to a lot
of japanese-americans there
they were put into detention camps as
questions of their loyalty were raised
in world war two now J Edgar Hoover he
he fought the Cold War very effectively
after the Second World War he had a lot
of information he was very good at his
job and he fought the Cold War
effectively what he and agents under him
did was basically great stuff during
that time they went after communists and
they went after radical leftists and
they did it pretty effectively they
deserve a lot of credit broadly speaking
I really like the guy I really like what
he was able to accomplish during his
tenure especially in the Cold War but
this is the big butt from the very
beginning the FBI itself was just
unacceptably powerful it is unacceptably
powerful from the very beginning the FBI
could spy on any American that it wants
to it could create lists for internment
camps it could it could tap phones it
and the line about this was that J Edgar
Hoover served for five decades because
everybody was afraid of him some of his
biographers recently have said oh that's
not true that's a legend that no way we
know it's true because the presidents
themselves said it Richard Nixon was
recorded in 1971 saying that he wouldn't
fire Hoover because he feared what
Hoover would do to him if you can spy on
every American if you can tap their
phones you're gonna get dirt on
everybody that's an insurance policy
President Truman said this to Truman
said quote we want no Gestapo or secret
police the FBI is tending in that
direction they are dabbling in sex life
scandals and plain blackmail J Edgar
Hoover would give his right eye to take
over and all congressmen and Senators
are afraid of him and he did that he
would find out generally people who
serve their whole lives in Congress or
the Senate or whatever they're pretty
depraved people they're pretty hollowed
out from within any all those guys in DC
of some weird sex scandal or something
in their past and so what Jagger Hoover
would do is he'd find out about that and
I was blackmail and he'd have it over
them and they would never fire Hoover
now we hear from a lot of lefties and we
hear from Trump critics on the on the
right how great the FBI is how Trump is
attacking the FBI the FBI is beyond
criticism their objective
public servants there and look there are
a lot of great people at the FBI totally
there are a lot of great FBI directors
there are a lot of great agents
especially a lot of great agents how
dare you how dare you quit we're
criticizing the FBI as an institution
Hoover himself was a great FBI director
but the nature of the agency means that
it requires constant unrelenting
vigilance by nature the FBI wants to
exceed its constitutional boundaries
it's right there look at all of the
power it has in its jobs and it's
wiretapping and its investigations it
has basically unchecked power we're
seeing this now we're seeing this in the
attempted coup of certain bureaucrats to
try to undo a presidential election
because it didn't turn out the way they
wanted it to turn out and and the FBI
has to be reined in we see this in the
text messages between what we see this
in the text messages that alluded to
that totally corrupt FBI agent Andy
McCabe deputy director we see it alluded
to in Peter struck and Lisa page those
those jilted lover text messages where
they talk about how they need to undo
the election how they don't want Trump
to win and they they want an insurance
policy and bla bla bla bla bla bill
kristol who for a long time has been a
conservative thought leader said in a
tweet in a horrifying tweet between the
deep state and the Trump State I choose
the deep state meaning the bureaucracy
meaning the unaccountable agencies
between the deep state and the Trump
State I want both I want to have both of
those I do want an effective national
security apparatus and I want it to
respect the American people and our
Constitution if we can't have both
you have decide with the Constitution
you have to side with the elected people
if we don't have that what is the FBI
protecting nothing nothing at all it is
people have had their perceptions of
this warped especially in DC especially
in the swampland where they are letting
the tail wag the dog they're putting the
cart before the horse
what other analogies can I come up with
they are prioritizing the agent of this
wonderful republic of ours over the
Republic itself not a good idea we we
can't be sentimental about this the left
wants us to be sentimental Trump's
critics want us to o/w the
glorious agencies how much I love
bureaucratic agencies give me my old
bureaucratic agencies no they're good
they serve a purpose they do good work
sometimes a lot of the time they do good
work and when they don't we got to rein
them in that's the way it is you got to
look at this with cold clear eyes and
free yourself to quote mr. West the
great political philosopher Kanye West
free yourself from a mental prison it'll
be very nice okay that's our show today
get your mailbag questions in so I can
free you from more mental prisons on
Thursday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Dole show is a daily wire
forward publishing production executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex Zangaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina herons
makeup is by Joshua Avera copyright
forward publishing 2018